hamas continues to fire hundreds of
rockets into civilian centers in israel
inflation numbers come out and they are
frightening and the biden administration
continues to lie about covet statistics
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first your reminder
again there are a lot of vpn providers
out there you've probably heard of a
couple of them
some of you may even have used a vpn
before to protect yourself from big tech
and from all of the hackers out there
who are looking for your information i
like to do research on my sponsors i
only recommend brands to my listeners i
believe in
that's why i've been talking for so long
about expressvpn expressvpn is the best
vpn on the market here are just a few
reasons why number one
expressvpn does not log your data there
are lots of really cheap or free vpns
that actually make money
by selling your data to ad companies
which is precisely the opposite of what
you want
from a vpn instead expressvpn developed
a technology it's called trusted server
that makes it impossible for their
servers to log any of your information
second it's really really fast a lot of
vpns will actually slow your connection
make it more difficult for you to do
what you need to do online
not express vpn my internet speeds
remain blazing fast the last thing
express vpn it's really easy to use i'm
talking like one click of a button
and you are good to go protect yourself
with the vpn i use and trust
use my link expressvpn.com today get an
extra three months for free
on a one year package that's
expressvpn.comben this is expressvpn.com
to learn more alrighty so overnight
hundreds more rocket attacks on israel
by hamas which is a terrorist group
a little bit of history for you hamas is
an openly
genocidal group they have said over and
over and over that they wish for israel
not to exist
this is not a conflict over land this is
not a conflict over borders this is not
a conflict over a right to return
this is a conflict in which one side
wishes to destroy the other side utterly
and completely and this has been their
long stated goal and they were about to
win an election by the way in the west
bank which is the reason for all of this
the
the recent history here is that in late
april
mahmoud abbas who again is a terrorist
mahmoud abbas treated as a legit
a legit world leader by much of the
world community but is not mahwas head
of the palestinian authority which is a
terrorist organization but a slightly
less terrorist organization than hamas
he had declared that there would be
elections in april the first elections
since 2004 he is now in the 16th year
of a four-year term mahmoud so he
declared elections then it appeared he
was going to lose so he cancelled the
elections
in late april and blamed the jews
because this is what you do
if you are a palestinian leader who is
suddenly
got their feet to the fire so mahmoud
abbas cancels the election he blames the
jews and he starts
ramping up calls for violence hamas not
to be outdone because the way that you
apparently garner support
is to show that you hate the jews even
more than the guy next to you hamas
decides they are going to ramp up the
violence this all culminates
in violence on the temple mount spurred
by hamas
spurred by fatah people using the
al-aqsa mosque
a holy site to muslims as an actual
staging base
to perform acts of terrorism and
violence against police officers israeli
police officers
and then when israel goes in to stop
that then
the rocket fire begins from hamas which
has decided to up
the ante so number one let's just
recognize the quick truth
none of this would be happening right
now in terms of this heavy rocket fire
from gaza if
israel had not unilaterally made the
concession in 2005 to pull out of the
gaza strip
completely remember israel had jewish
areas of the gaza
there were jewish areas in the northern
gaza strip there were these little
cities in the northern gaza strip they
had greenhouses they were quite
prosperous in 2005 israel unilaterally
withdrew
in order supposedly to push for a new
peace deal the idea was going to be look
israel is giving up this land and now
it's another it's another
stone in the wall of peace that's going
to be built right here instead hamas
immediately rushed in burned all the
greenhouses and then started building up
its rocket bases
for use against the state of israel and
what this has resulted in
is most of israel is now under the
umbrella of terror
from the north israel is under the
umbrella of hezbollah which is an
iranian bacterial group in lebanon
they have apparently 150 000 rockets if
you think it's bad right now with hamas
firing hundreds of rockets today
wait until it's hezbollah firing
thousands of rockets today
and then from the south they are under
assault from hamas a terrorist group
located
in the gaza strip palestinian islamic
chihuahua is located in both
judea samaria the west bank and the gaza
strip
so israel israeli citizens basically
live under the constant threat that at
any moment things could go up in flames
and all of a sudden they could be living
underground so i was texting with a
bunch of friends in israel last night
who were literally texting from bunkers
many of them had been giving 45 second
60-second 90-second warnings to get
underground
as soon as humanly possible because the
fact is that israel is a tiny tiny
country
and it is a tiny country surrounded by
malevolent countries that do not wish it
do not wish it well this is why the
trump breakthrough in terms of actually
creating alliances and helping to foster
alliances between israel and places like
the
united arab emirates and places like
sudan and places like morocco
why this was such a good thing the biden
administration immediately blew it
okay so there are a few events that led
up to this one was abbas cancelling the
election
and then having to demonstrate to the
palestinians that mostly it was israel
and we need to blame israel and
let's have a competition as to who hates
israel most it's also a smart move by
abbas
in the sense that hamas in going all the
way in shooting rockets
into israel was going to be also the
chief recipient of israeli return fire
so abbas is basically having the
israelis do his dirty work by killing
off al hamas leadership
so this is one of the things that's
happening as well the other thing that
happened is that the biden
administration upon entering office
immediately signified that it wanted to
push israel into making concessions to
these terror groups
that will restore funding to the unrwa
which is an agency specifically
dedicated
toward fostering palestinian extremism
that the that the united states would
restore 290 million dollars worth of
foreign aid
to the palestinian authority much of
which would be used
for for terrorism and fostering of
terrorism
okay so the united states basically
reopened the door the trump
administration
said no we are making very clear who our
allies are here and if you engage in
terror
the money didn't come in your way and
things were calm and things were quiet
and then the administration came in and
within months you have this massive
conflagration which is now
on the verge of all-out war and the
reason it's on the verge of all that war
is because israel literally has millions
of its citizens
now living underground okay so to
understand this conflict the thing you
really need to understand is the map
okay so there are a few maps i'm going
to show you right now the first map
shows you
the actual range of fire from gaza okay
the distances
from the gaza strip to various israeli
cities
okay what you'll see here is that the
distances are tiny israel is a tiny
postage stamp
of a country the distance from gaza the
gaza strip
which is located in the in the southwest
corner of israel
the the so the the
distance from the gaza strip to ashkelon
which is a city that has been under
steady rocket fire over the course of
the last three days is about 13 miles
that's the distance 13 miles the
distance from the gaza strip to tel aviv
this was considered a long shot for
hamas until recently
that distance is about 44 miles okay not
a long
uh less than a less than an hour car
ride
significantly less than an hour car ride
the distance from gaza to jerusalem
which is sort of in the center of the
country is only 47 miles from gaza to
ashdod it's 24 miles okay what does this
mean
it means that when you fire rockets
people have pretty much no warning
here is a map of the warning times when
a rocket is fired okay if
a rocket were to be fired from
essentially
gaza to ashdod you'd be talking about at
most 30 seconds of warning time if
you're talking about gaza to jerusalem
you're talking about 1.5 minutes
of warning time about 90 seconds of
warning time if you're talking about to
tel aviv about the same a little bit
under 90 seconds of warning time that
means that if you're woken up at 3 am
by a rocket siren going off you now have
90 seconds to grab your kids
and get down into a bomb shelter before
the rockets start to hit
okay so hamas knowing this has been
firing hundreds of rockets in israel the
reason they're firing hundreds of
rockets simultaneously
is because their goal is to overwhelm
israel's iron defense system so israel
has an iron
iron dome system it's called the iron
dome system and the iron's home system
is largely
relegated to shooting down missiles that
are going to land in populated areas so
tel aviv has an iron dome system
jerusalem has an iron dome system and
it's very effective it shoots down about
90 of these rockets
but here's the problem as you increase
the number of rockets that are fired
the additional 10 in absolute numbers
starts to go up
so here is a map of the rocket alerts
these are the sirens
just over the last 30 this is over a 30
minute period last night
as you can see the entire map is red
right the entire map
from ashdod in the south all the way up
to hadera in the north
is completely is completely red okay the
reason is because they were firing
hundreds of rockets they fired over a
thousand rockets over the course of the
last 36
hours from the gaza strip into israel
they don't care who they hit
okay they don't care last night hamas
killed an israeli arab father and
seven-year-old girl
in lode which is a city that right now
is actually in in the middle of of
race riots essentially okay so hamas
started this conflict hamas clearly
started the conflict and now israel has
no choice if
and no country can sustain this right no
country can allow its citizenry to be
put underground by a terrorist group
israel has every moral obligation to go
in and decapitate the entire hamas
regime
what comes next who the hell knows but
israel has a moral obligation to go in
and kill every hamas and palestinian
islamic jihad leader
they can find and in fact this is what
benjamin netanyahu the prime minister of
israel is saying it's not just netanyahu
it's not just
about netanyahu yeah you're lapid who's
in the opposition feels the same way
the benigns who's in the opposition
feels the same way as the current
defense minister
okay the the there's widespread israeli
acknowledgement that just like if
you in your city were put underground by
a terrorist group living across the
border
and you're told that you had to live in
the basement and you were going to live
in under constant rocket fire you would
expect the american government to go and
eviscerate that regime
well the same thing should be expected
of any decent state in israel of course
has a moral obligation to defend
its own citizens as even most members of
the west acknowledge now
most members of the west also then
participate in this moral equivalence
game where they pretend that israel is
somehow an aggressor here which is a
complete lie
but as israel does have the obligation
to do this benjamin netanyahu
came out yesterday and said yeah we are
not going to stop anytime soon like if
you think that you're going to get a
ceasefire here
no the answer is no you don't get to
fire thousands of rockets into israel
and then survive that's not just that's
not something that you get to do
over 850 rockets have crossed into
israeli territory after being launched
from gaza by the way how little does
hamas care about its own citizens
when people say it's therefore terrible
for the palestinians that's true
the palestinians are not of concern to
hamas hamas does not care
200 of the rockets that they fired fell
into gaza
okay they fired 200 rockets that landed
on their own people they don't
care so defense minister benny gonz said
that the idf the israeli defense forces
will continue striking gaza until it can
bring a complete and long-term peace
during a visit to ashkelon on wednesday
he said in the last few hours the idf
has carried out a series of significant
attacks we've attacked squads of
commanders and significant hamas
infrastructure will continue to protect
all residents of israel we've attacked
many hundreds of targets towers are
falling factories are collapsing tunnels
are being destroyed commanders are
assassinated
all the means and all the options are on
the table there's a lot more activity in
the bank
he said the idf will continue to attack
and bring a complete long-term piece
only when we achieve this goal can we
talk about calm there is currently no
end date we will not accept moral
sermons from any organization or
institution about our right and duty to
protect israeli citizens again benigns
is is opposition to benjamin netanyahu
this is not about netanyahu this is not
about likud dance is not a member of the
clude there's widespread israeli
sentiment as there would be in the
united states that if democrat or
republican
there were there were hundreds of
rockets falling on san diego from mexico
there would be a widespread sentiment
the united states government needs to go
in and pacify
the folks who are doing that well the
same thing is happening in israel
right now to that end israel has knocked
out several
commanders of the of hamas and islamic
jihad they'll continue to do that
hey well we actually have video of
what's been happening in the gaza strip
so a few things one hamas is one of the
most evil groups on earth they fire
rockets deliberately from civilian areas
they deliberately fire rockets from
civilian areas because they know that if
israel were to respond
israel would have to kill civilians in
order to stop the rocket fire and they
know that israel is loath to do that
because israel is actually a moral state
as opposed to hamas which is a deeply
deeply evil group here is video of hamas
firing rockets from the middle of
civilian areas these are these are
civilian apartment buildings that are
surrounding
the the firing sites for the gaza strip
you can see these are apartment
buildings right this is right in the
middle of a populated area they're
firing these rockets
directly from the middle of streets in
the gaza strip
the goal here is that if israel were to
take out those batteries then israel
would have to hit
those civilian areas okay and by the way
a few other notes you'll notice that
when these rockets are being fired
in the tapes you will see that there are
onlockers and these onlookers
are not are are not just kind of
watching this go on they're shouting ala
huakbar
they're onlookers who are shouting their
celebration that these rockets are being
fired on israel now
israelis require that their government
actually defend them obviously because
any government should defend its
citizens but you're not going to see
israelis out in the streets
cheering as rockets or bombs fall on
hamas buildings
just as the united states there is no
cheering in the streets when the united
states was bombing the taliban
okay because that is something that you
do more in sorrow than in anger
right something you don't want to do it
except apparently if if rockets are
being fired on random jews remember
these are not
rockets that are targeted at military
sites in israel these are rockets
that are that are being randomly fired
toward the most populated areas of
israel
they don't care who they kill israeli
arabs don't matter
babies it doesn't matter they do not
care they don't care
it is that simple okay here are the
americas shouting allahu akbar as these
rockets go off to presumably attempt to
kill as many children and
and women and innocents and civilians as
possible
[Music]
these sets of rockets being fired off
and people celebrating and cheering
what is it like but don't worry there's
moral equivalence according to
the west okay so in a second we'll show
you some more footage of what is going
on over in israel and then we'll get to
the insanity of a west that somehow
declares moral equivalence here it is
quite wild we'll get to that in just a
moment first let's talk about a simple
fact if you're a responsible person you
need life insurance right
it's just something you need you want to
make sure that your family is taken care
of in case god forbid
something should happen to you well
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place
why compare well you can save 50 or more
on life insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius
you could save 1300 or more per year on
life insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies
the licensed experts at policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews
on trustpilot and google first head on
over to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
you can compare personalized quotes and
find your best price when you're ready
to apply
the policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and the scheduling for free
policy genius never sells your
information to other companies
they don't add on extra fees head on
over to policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and very important to get it
right go get the life insurance you need
at the best available price that's
policygenius.com
go check them out right now alrighty so
israel has this miraculous system called
iron dome
it's been able to shoot down the vast
majority of these rockets that enter
over civilian areas the footage is
astonishing here's some of the footage
of rockets over tel aviv you can see in
this footage
the rockets that are that are flying
over tel aviv and then you can see
other anti-missiles essentially coming
up from the ground
and knocking it's a bullet hitting a
bullet with like 90 efficacy it's
unbelievable the efficiency is
incredible it looks like something from
star wars
because it is in fact there are israelis
who are still retaining their sense of
humor
who uh who put the star wars theme music
over what iron dome has been doing here
the goal here of course is to overwhelm
iron dome by firing so many rockets
simultaneously
that the iron dome system is not capable
of knocking out all the rockets at once
but imagine this happening over a city
where you live
imagine that there's just a bunch of
rockets and all you can do is sit there
and wait for the thing to fall on you
or for iron dome to shoot it down and in
some cases obviously
it hasn't worked there's a direct impact
for example on a school in ashkelon
see here's the difference between the
israelis and the palestinians in the
gaza strip
hamas the palestinian rulership in the
gaza strip hamas
the difference is that the israelis
specifically avoid
targeting schools right the in the
the hamas the hamas terrorists
literally put their military bases in
schools that that is the difference so
this is a school that was hit directly
by a rocket thank god all the kids were
not there otherwise presumably hundreds
of kids would have been killed
they were also firing at ben gurion
airport they were trying to kill as many
people as possible and to shut down air
travel to the state of israel
so this is the actual footage from ben
gurion airport you can see
the rockets firing over ben gurion
airport and you can see them being shot
down
by the iron dome system over in cologne
which is a which is an outskirt of tel
aviv again it's about 45 miles
from from the gaza strip uh
a bus was hit directly by rocket fire
apparently one person was killed in this
in this particular attack into the bus
flaming from the rocket fire
another moss rocket hit the trans-israel
oil pipeline
uh which of course does no good to the
citizens of the gaza strip because some
of them actually get their power from
this sort of thing
and so set the uh the trans-israel
pipeline on fire and meanwhile
is it here's how is it so that's how
hamas treats this conflict right just
shoot
rockets everywhere see if you can hit
anything it's basically the game
battleship you just randomly just shoot
things
at people and hope that it hit somebody
okay here is how
israel handles this stuff so here is
tape
of a palestinian security guard being
called by the israeli military
and told get everybody out of this
building we know that hamas uses this
building so we're knocking down the
building
that's literally what's happening here
israel calls minutes before they're
about to hit a building
they call whoever they can get and they
say get all the civilians out
he's saying at least two to three hours
no one should come close so i should go
to the other building and not let anyone
come close
no problem no problem so first one shot
warning and then two missiles
i'm asking you first you'll warn and
then you'll hit the building
i just want to make sure that there's no
one inside okay so this is a person
talking to the israeli military the
israeli military
is literally giving up the element of
surprise which is the number one element
in warfare particularly when you're
talking about
terrorists who are embedded in the
middle of civilian populations they're
saying okay we'd rather not kill the
terrorists
who will then fire more rockets on us in
order to get the civilians out of the
way
okay and then the propaganda that is
printed by the media is that israel is
knocking down towers without any mention
of this sort of stuff
okay so here hamas put out this video of
israel knocking down this apartment
complex right hitting this apartment
complex
israel you know how they know that that
apartment
why do they know where to turn the
camera how do they know where to train
the camera
the answer is they know where to train
the camera because israel dropped a
knock bomb
on top of that a knock bomb is a bomb
that is designed not to penetrate the
top
layer of the apartment complex they drop
a bomb it shakes the building then break
the building
everybody gets out and then they knock
down the building so that is how israel
treats all of this
meanwhile in what is actually the most
devastating element of all of this not
the
not the actual terror attacks from hamas
which is somewhat expected
the most devastating part of all of this
is the situation and load so
israel has about 20 of its population is
arab
about 80 percent of its population is
jewish and
typically in israel those populations
don't live in close proximity with one
another
typically you'll have sort of a jewish
city and then an arab city that's right
across the way right
that's fairly typical in israel there
are a couple cities that are an
exception to this rule one of those
cities is load load is considered sort
of a model city
in this way and it is kind of amazing i
mean last time i was in israel a couple
years ago
my cell phone broke i had to go to the
nearest mall that had some sort of cell
phone repair shop
and that mall happened to be a load so i
went there and
orthodox jews walking around the same
malls as arabs and
and everybody getting along and
basically that city is 70 jewish 30
arab and everybody lives in pretty close
quarters
well now thanks to hamas and fatah
ramping up the violence
there were riots in the city of lode in
which arab citizens were going out and
burning down
synagogues two separate synagogues were
burned down three jewish schools were
burned down and a bunch of jews were
threatened in their own homes
requiring evacuation by the idf and now
a state of emergency has been declared
in load which again
was a was a city in which people were
basically living together fine
now a state of emergency was declared in
load with defense minister benny gonce
according to the jerusalem post
announcing the deployment of several
border police units to help quell
violence that saw the burning of three
synagogues and dozens of cars
at least two people were in serious
condition from the clashes one from
rocks
and akko which is another that's
actually where i got married it's
another mixed arab jewish city in
northern israel an 84 year old man was
seriously hurt when a restaurant was set
on fire
by rioters some 25 residents of ramla
and load were arrested on tuesday night
according to the police spokesperson 151
were arrested in total within the
central northern district
of israel lord mayor yaya revivo said
we've lost control of the city and the
streets
israel police chief kobe shabtai said
we've not seen this kind of violence
since october 2000 which was the last
intifada lori bury is a popular jewish
owned fish restaurant
in in akka that had been set ablaze as
well it's an akko
uh that it had been set in ablaze in
yafo there's been
violence so internacing racial violence
has now been taking place
prompted presumably not presumably
realistically by arab citizens who
are in solidarity with hamas and with
fatah okay all of this is disastrous and
so the question becomes why exactly is
all this happening
right now why is all this happening
right now we'll get to the answer to
that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
own
assets the reality is that your most
valuable asset is probably your home
title
right not your home right nobody's going
to come and steal your home but they can
steal the value inheritance in your home
title if you're on facebook the big
breach is here facebook had 500 million
accounts exposed
to cyber thieves according to a retired
fbi cyber crime expert
everything thieves that need to take
over as the new owner of your home was
leaked name address personal information
it's out
a thief can forge your signature on a
quitclaim deed saying you sold your home
to him
and then he can start taking out credit
against your home and leave you in debt
or even have you evicted
instead just go to home title lock and
make sure that your home's title is
locked up home title lock go to home
title lock.com right now
register your address to see if you're
already a victim then sign up for 30
free days of protection during this high
risk breach again
go to home title lock dot com use promo
code radio that is home
title lock dot com promo code radio you
know you lock your safe at night you
make sure that you don't leave your
jewelry out
all your valuables you make sure that
you protect them why wouldn't you
protect your most valuable asset your
home title
go check out hometitlelock.com right now
use promo code radio and get 30 free
days
of protection during this high risk
breach alrighty so
why is all of this happening right now
the answer is all this is happening
right now
because the biden administration came
into power and because mahmoud abbas
decided that he was going to cancel
elections
that's why the biden administration came
into power they decided they were going
to make overtures to the iranian regime
they were going to make concessions to
the iranian regime they're going to
shame the saudis they're going to try
and cut off relations essentially with
the saudis
they're going to try and pressure arab
states not to warm up
their their peace with israel they're
going to try and broker some sort of
agreement between israel and the
palestinian authority by pressuring
israel
they're going right back to the same
failed model that has been tried for
some
30 years in the united states pressure
our ally not
isolate our enemies the reality is hamas
hates america hates america palestinian
islamic jihad
hates america palestinian authority
hates america these are people who do
not like the united states
hamas is explicitly backed by the
iranian regime you wonder how they got
all this technology
israel has been kind of stunned by the
ability of hamas to fire these
long-range rockets
why because iran has been shipping that
technology
through the gaza strip okay and the
united states is standing right there
trying to reinstate good relations with
an iranian regime that openly declares
death to america and death to israel
what america does makes a difference the
united states basically isolated the
palestinian
authority they said listen if you guys
want to make peace anytime you want to
you can
otherwise all the arab states they're
going to just recognize that you are not
top priority they're going to make peace
with israel in order
to counter the rising threat of iran and
so you get a bunch of peace deals
and then the biden regime came in
and they decided you know what we don't
care about those peace deals what we
want to do is we want to
revivify this idiotic notion that iran
is going to be a regional force for
stability which is insane
it was pushed by barack obama joe biden
has re-embraced it okay this has led to
the stupidity of morons like david frum
suggesting well you know that
what happens all those cushion or trump
people bragging about peace the answer
is they actually achieve peace within
the first four months you have achieved
war
within the first four months joe biden
has given
all the green lights to all the
conditions for for a new intifada
so the worst conflict in this region
since 2006
okay that is because of joe biden okay
the last time we had this sort of
conflict was 2014 that was under barack
obama
there was quiet in the region for four
years you know why that was because when
america sides with its allies
there is no conflict when america does
not side with its allies there is
conflict
every time concessions are made to
terrorists they immediately are
emboldened
and proceed to engage in this sort of
activity
and so it does make a difference that
the west has decided to take attack of
moral equivalents
along these lines okay the the
the amazing part of all of this truly is
that
there this moral equivalence is even
being drawn i mean it just demonstrates
the moral blindness
of so many people here's jen sackey from
the white house
drawing moral equivalents the
president's support for israel's
security
for its legitimate right to defend
itself and its people is fundamental and
will never
waver we condemn ongoing rocket attacks
by hamas and other terrorist groups
including against jerusalem
we also stand against extremism that has
inflicted violence on both communities
we stand that last part is the amazing
part we stand against extremism that has
inflicted violence on both communities
um excuse me right now that first
statement is the one that's supposed to
matter
the hell are you talking about extremism
that has inflicted
but you have thousands of rockets being
fired into civilian areas right now
israel has a right to defend itself the
first part of the statement's fine
the last part where she tries to come
back around and then do the cycle of
violence routine
is just nonsense recognize that really
what this started with was a bunch of
tick tock videos of palestinians beating
the living hell out of jews in jerusalem
fomented by fatah because fatal wanted
to distract from the fact that he just
canceled elections
meanwhile hamas's leader ismail khane
who lives over in qatar
because he is scared of living in the
gaza strip he's afraid that israel will
knock him out
he's been tweeting out the bombing of
tel aviv and the oil pipeline facility
between ashkelon and elat god is great
and glory is to god alone
he also tweeted out a friend called me a
little while ago and told me laughing
many unfortunately the servants of those
whom i know from here and there
and you know where exactly are very
angry and humiliation breaks them and
oppression pervades them because you o
heroes have broken their thorns and
destroyed the zionists while hiding in
shelters below the earth
mourning for their persecution which
went in vain
okay by the way this is the leader of
hamas he's the leader of hamas
moral equivalence uh unreal
but don't worry and by the way did
twitter ban ismael hanya nope
he's still there it'll ban trump but not
somebody who's openly celebrating
terrorism
how about ayatollah khamenei right these
are the people that the biden
administration is trying to make
concessions to the iranian regime he
tweeted out
palestinians are awake and determined
they must continue this path
one can only talk with the language of
power with these criminals they must
increase their strength stand strong
confront the enemy and force them to
stop their crimes hashtag free palestine
so just to get this straight facebook
and twitter banned
trump but they won't ban this piece of
human debris
pretty incredible stuff okay the good
news is that
the radical left in the united states
which is increasingly the mainstream
left in the united states is openly
siding with the bad guys here
so alexander ocasio is very angry with
andrew yang andrew yang is running for
mayor of new york
he looks likely to win which is a good
thing andrew yang had tweeted out his
support for israel so she got mad
she then tweeted out utterly shameful
for yang to show up to an aid event
after sending out a chest-thumping
statement of support for a strike
killing nine children
especially after his silence as al-aqsa
was attacked but then try that in
astoria during ramadan
they will let you know okay so um a few
things that are just open lies all oxo
is not attacked the only people who
attacked al-aqsa
are members of hamas and fatah literally
took over the building brought rocks in
from the from the surrounding temple
mount and fireworks and proceeded to
fling them at israeli soldiers and build
barricades so as to do violence in the
middle of ramadan
there is no obscurity about this there
is no opacity about this it is perfectly
clear what happened there there's
there's video i showed it here so she's
just lying
as far as a chest stumping statement of
support for a strike killing nine
children
israel has been attempting to kill hamas
members hamas members deliberately hide
themselves behind
children knowing that morons like aoc
will then blame israel for defending
itself rather than the hamas people who
are hiding behind
children what a moral cretan she is
my goodness bernie sanders similarly
immoral
he tweeted out i am extremely concerned
by the growing conflict in israel and
palestine
once again we are seeing how the
irresponsible actions of government
allied right-wing extremists in
jerusalem can escalate quickly into
devastating war the f
is he talking about he's just making
things up right now
israeli children should not have to
spend the night scared in bomb shelters
as many are doing tonight
well that's true rockets should not be
fired palestinian children should not
have to grow up under the constant
violence and oppression of occupation as
so many do and have done
gaza is ruled by hamas israel does not
rule the gaza strip the palestinian
authority rules judea and samaria it is
not ruled by israel
israel just does not allow people to
ship weapons in
and out and controls its own border
that's all
bernie sanders then continues the united
states must call for an immediate
cease-fire and an end to provocative and
illegal settlements activity this is not
about settlements are you insane
hell is this about settlements they're
firing on ashkelon they're firing on
ashdod they're chanting bomb bomb tel
aviv
on the temple mount we must also
recommit to working with israelis and
palestinians to finally end this
conflict what a joke he is
what an absolute more what soviet
unbel what he's just disgusting
truly the the the number of people on
the radical left have been mainstreamed
in the democratic party
is truly an astonishing astonishing
thing and the media will continue to
allow lies
to be promulgated the same media that
will tell you that that
fake news is really really dangerous
they'll just allow lies to be
promulgated so
they'll have on a an msnbc guess they
had a palestinian on msnbc
not sure the name of this guest and uh
he was very angry that anybody would be
upset with hamas he says you know the
u.s has waged more wars than there are
hamas members
um excuse me
the united states has raised more wars
than there are hamas members
i don't wait for the united states to
tell me what
constitutes that self-defense and what
not constitutes a self-defense
um that is not where my moral compass
stems from
i don't think the the the united states
is in position
giving all of the genocides and wars
it's partaking and to say something
about
who has the right to self defense he
sounds exactly like ilhan omar he sounds
exactly like prosciutto talib he sounds
exactly like koc he sounds like bernie
sanders right
the the international terrorist movement
uses the talking points of the left on a
routine basis
right america doesn't have any moral
credibility to call against rocket fire
indiscriminately aimed at civilians
because after all you guys are really
bad
it's it's pretty incredible it's
bringing and then of course you have
trevor noah who just tells open laws
right trevor noah actively defended
hamas last night on his show
if you start from israel fired rockets
into gaza
well then israel is the bad guy because
they're bombing gaza
but then you take a step back in time
you go well hamas fired rockets at
israel
well then hamas is the bad guy but then
you take a step back and you go but
the israeli police they went in and
started
beating people up in a mosque during
ramadan the most holy time in the muslim
calendar
well then israel is the bad guy okay
well except for your lying
that didn't happen
okay again the number of lies that have
to be told in order to reach the point
of moral equivalence between a state
that seeks to defend its citizens
including israeli arabs who by the way
were again murdered by hamas last night
between a state that has a 20 terror
population that
attempts to warn people before they kill
terrorists
and a group of people who openly declare
that they want to wipe every jew off the
face of the earth
and fire thousands of rockets
indiscriminately into civilian centers
you know the mental gymnastics that you
have to do in order to get there the
moral pretzeling you have to do
these folk makes these folks morally
make cirque du soleil
look like nothing it's unreal the moral
flexibility you have to have
at a certain point the rubber band has
to break here it's pretty it's pretty
insane
already we're going to get to the
inflation which is cropping up plus
more lies from the cdc first i'm sure
you've noticed our country
is feeling less and less free lockdown
extensions and cancel culture everything
we do and consume is weaponized
every single thing from the education we
receive to the movies we watch the shoes
we wear on our feet you're not alone in
noticing this you may have noticed that
your boss is telling you what to think
or training you
in diversity so that you feel bad about
the color of your skin you may have
noticed that your kids are being
subjected to indoctrination at their
school
you may have noticed that the media is
just lying to you well i wrote an entire
book about the institutional takeover of
the united states and how to fight back
against it is called the authoritarian
moment
in it i give some background on how we
got here how each individual institution
in american life from the scientific
community
all the way to hollywood was taken over
and how and how we fight back that's the
most important part because you have to
understand how we got here
in order to reverse the process so if
you want to preserve your individual
rights if you want
to organize a taking back of our
institutions go check out my book today
the authoritarian moment is available
for pre-order
at amazon barnes and noble any other
major bookseller
i think it's deeply important stuff i
think it's a really important book i
wrote it at white heat i mean
some books are hard to write this one i
wrote it super fast because i want to
get it out to you as fast as possible
the authoritarian moment available for
pre-order right now at amazon barnes and
noble or any other
major bookseller you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile inflation is
cropping up in the united states amazing
how joe biden has somehow prompted an
intifada so
unrest in the middle east uh more
powerful iran
he has prompted inflation and gas lines
the we're back to jimmy carter this is
great
really excellent excellent stuff i mean
they're about the same age so it makes
make some sense
inflation is back okay according to
yahoo news u.s inflation is expected to
jump 3.6
in april alone economist forecast u.s
consumer prices
are expected to have risen by 3.6 in
april over their level a year ago
a prospect already spooking markets and
could fuel concern that inflationary
pressures are setting in
according to a consensus forecast
assembled by definitive the bureau of
labor statistics will
on wednesday report that its consumer
price index rose from 2.6
in march to 3.6 percent last month
compared with the same month
in 2020. stripping out food and energy
costs the cpi is expected to rise from
1.6
in march to 2.3 in april on an annual
basis
okay and and the truth is that it is
worse than that
okay according to the consumer price
index summary from the bls the index for
all items less food and energy rose
0.9 in april its largest monthly
increase since
april 1982. see the biggest inflationary
increase
in 40 years happening right now
again this according to the bureau of
labor statistics the government source
nearly all major component indices
increased in april along with the index
for used cars and trucks
the indices for shelter airline fares
recreation motor vehicle insurance and
household furnishings and operations
were among the indices with a large
impact on the overall increase
the all items index rose 4.2 percent for
the 12 months ending in april
a larger increase than the 2.6 percent
increase for the period ending march
similarly the index for all items less
food and energy rose 3.0
over the last 12 months a larger
increase than the 1.6 rise over the
12-month period ending in march so in
other words we have now
basically doubled the inflation rate
over the course of the last month
or so the energy index rose 25.1 percent
over the last 12 months the food index
increased 2.4
percent so i mean unbelievable levels of
inflation setting in
almost immediately despite the fact that
you've got the entire biden
administration saying there's no
no problem to see here here's jen sackey
at the white house literally yesterday
saying any inflation will be transitory
of course we take uh the possibility of
inflation quite seriously
as you know actions that have been taken
to date or proposals that have been made
most economic analysts believe that it
will have a temporary
transitory impact but in terms of
analysis on current events i would point
you to the federal reserve
okay and uh quick note where's joe biden
he's completely missing in action
you got a conflict in the middle east
you have a massive inflation hitting
you have gas shortages that have
basically knocked out
half the gas stations on the east coast
and joe biden is nowhere he's watching
matlock
well done everybody well but at least
there are no mean tweets at least you
don't have any means tweets that's
that's really you know important stuff
no mean tweets
well the good news is that every crisis
is an opportunity energy secretary
jennifer granholm yesterday
she said the good news is that if we're
going to have these gas shortages
remember we've had a giant pipeline
the colonial pipeline that was hacked so
that meant that that basically
gas went down most of this week in terms
of its supply
all over the southeast coast and all the
way up into new jersey
energy secretary grantham says well you
know the good news is at least this will
push us toward a great new deal
you know if you drive an electric car
this would not be affecting you
clearly the broader issue is a very
important issue it's
an issue for the president's priority in
the american jobs plan
the issue of investing in a transmission
grid for example so that you don't have
the cyber
issues associated with it so there's a
lot of broader questions in this
and we hope that we'll be able to see
that investment in
infrastructure that will facilitate
clean and renewable energy
i mean amazing so she's really she's
smiling about it look at her she's like
she's gleeful about this this is gonna
facilitate green new deal stuff i mean
sure it's costing you like a fortune at
the pump sure you can't even get gas
but everything is going great because it
facilitates the agenda
crisis is always an opportunity for
these people it's always an opportunity
for these people
okay meanwhile on covid the unemployment
rate continues to be artificially high
we all know why that is it's because the
biden administration is paying people to
stay home
so last night the the chief of chipotle
the restaurant officer
was on cnn explaining that the reason we
can't get any employees is because you
keep paying people to stay home
a half dozen states now have announced
that they're going to end those benefits
before they expire
is that the right move i certainly
believe so i think it encourages folks
to get back to work there are a number
of jobs available across
all the industry today uh and for us to
continue to grow the economy here in the
us we've got to have people ready
and willing to engage get back to work
and continue to drive the economy
okay it is perfectly true that the biden
administration is driving people out of
the workforce but the good news is that
we have a president who just is fighting
the teleprompter he's not fighting
inflation he's not fighting unemployment
he's certainly not fighting for our
allies around the world ranging from
taiwan to israel but
he's definitely fighting the
teleprompter he is locked in a death
match with the teleprompter
and help us get there we've added two
new tools
one americans can go to
vaccines.gov
or they can text their zip code
to three excuse me bespoke
their zip code text it to four
three eight eight two nine the senile
old codger
out there doing nothing for a living
except pushing radicalism and fostering
instability all around the globe really
really well done well good news is we
have experts in charge
like for example we have cdc chief
rachel wolenski so she should have been
fired long ago you remember just a few
weeks ago she said she had a feeling of
doom
an interior an inner feeling of doom
we're all going to die unless we got
vaccinated three times and also wore
a triple mask and hopefully a bag over
our head and we like a plastic bag and
then we took some duct tape wrapped
around our neck you wouldn't die of cove
if you did that 100 guaranteed well
here she was yesterday cdc chief
wolenski
saying she told her 16 year old son that
he can't go to summer camp this year
which is asinine number one the
vaccine's already been approved for 16
year olds
number two he's 16. he's not going to
die from covid number three
he is outdoors the hell are you talking
about
and these tool bags are supposed to
represent the science to science ooh
here's rochelle wolinski being
completely a scientific butt very angry
about it
i have a 16 year old every day every
year he comes home from camp and he
writes the number of days until he
returns to camp the next year
this year it got to zero and i told him
he wasn't going
i want our kids back in camp
we now have 38 000 new infections on
average
per day last may 11th it was 24
000 and we sent a lot of kids home and
camps were closed
the camp guidance is intended to get our
kids to camp
and allow them to stay there okay this
is just ridiculous okay she she just
compared the stats from this year to
last year
do you remember this time last year we
didn't have the tests available
the number of tests that we were
tranching out was like one quarter
one-fifth of what we are tranching out
right now it was much
much lower if you're comparing the
infection rates in may
of 2020 to the infection rates in may of
2021 you're out of your damned mind
based on the stats that she is citing
right there
okay but again she's not representing
the science she's just representing
politics this is all politics susan
collins who is certainly no rabid
right-winger accused the cdc of using
faulty data in its recent mass guidance
for the outdoors the agency announced
last month
that less than 10 of transmission was
occurring outdoors except that that was
wildly misleading according to the new
york times
according to the new york times when the
cdc released a new guidelines last month
for mask wearing it announced that less
than 10
of kova 19 transmission was occurring
outdoors media organizations repeated
the stat
it quickly became a standard description
of the frequency of outdoor transmission
but that number is almost certainly
misleading it appears to be based partly
on a misclassification of some coveted
transmission that actually took place in
enclosed spaces
an even bigger issue is the extreme
caution of cdc officials who picked a
benchmark ten percent
so high that nobody could reasonably
dispute it doctor much sevik a
virologist at the university of
university of saint andrews said the
benchmark appears to be a huge
exaggeration
in truth the share of transmission that
has occurred outdoors seems to be below
one percent and maybe
0.1
0.1 hey do you understand
the difference between zero point one
percent and ten percent
okay that means that you are off by a
factor of
one thousand right you're
correct like what in the world what in
the actual hell
like hold on one second 10 divided by
0.1
10 divided by 0.1 just to make sure i
got the numbers right you're off by a
factor of 100 here
you're off by a factor of 100. they said
that
under 10 okay that's like saying that
under 1 million airplanes fall out of
the sky every year that's true
under a million airplanes fall out of
the sky every year the answer is much
closer to
zero okay so the cdc just lied with
stats that's how you lie with statistics
as the new york times says saying that
less than 10 of kova transmission occurs
outdoors is akin to saying that sharks
attack fewer than 20 000 swimmers a year
the actual worldwide number is around
150.
it's both true and deceiving this isn't
just a gotcha math issue it's an example
of how the cdc is struggling to
communicate effectively
or alternatively they are communicating
effectively they're just communicating
lies
the why they are communicating is that
everything is crisis mode you gotta have
kids
wear masks at camp outdoors in 90 degree
heat we have to pretend that outdoor
transmission is going to be widespread
we have to pretend like wallenski just
lied there that
transmission levels are at the same rate
they were in may of last year
all of this is insane okay but this is
what is being pushed
by this administration lies that lead to
economic uncertainty lies that lead to
inflation policies that lead to worse
outcomes for americans
policies that lead to more
conflagrations around the globe
it's incredible this guy this
administration was supposed to return to
normalcy i'm waiting to feel the normal
are you feeling the normal yet
this should be a period of optimism we
were told this is going to be the
booming 20s not the stagflation 70s
instead we're getting the 70s we're
going to get oil embargoes we're going
to i mean like
this is ridiculous we're getting gas
lines we're getting inflation we're
getting stagflation well like
and we're getting all of this because of
bad policy policy
makes a difference it makes a large
difference and i know
that everybody was very up in arms about
the stuff that trump said i hated a lot
of it too but guess what at the end of
the day the policy implemented by the
white house
makes a lot more difference in american
lives than whatever dumb crap people put
on twitter
okay but unfortunately we live in a
world in which we are supposed to
pretend that the crap people say on
twitter is of significantly more
importance than what actually happens
on the ground and the people paying the
price for that right now are you
waiting in line for gas and you at the
grocery store now having to pay twice
what you're going to pay
and you yes you israelis living in
bunkers under your cities right now
unreal alrighty we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out the michael
moles show on today's episode o.j
simpson
endorses liz cheney which is weird it's
just
all of life all of politics is just mad
libs right now that episode is available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
israel breaks out into violence ted cruz
rips up the corrupt politicians act
liz cheney wins the coveted endorsement
of o.j simpson check it out on the
michael knoll show